le moment
3 heures du matin non excusez moi mais
là j'ai une inspiration de manager me
prouver le thème de ma série ses démons
eric judor le plus grands créatifs de
tous les temps a un problème et non je
crois car nations trucks avec les angles
notion je crois tout à fait normal c'est
un gros problème
j'ai été clair dans une autre vie je
comprends pourquoi j'ai un karma de
maire depuis dix ans le chien et pour y
remédier il va devoir retrouver la foi
et rassembler ses fidèles je suis maudit
ce rythme news nous est venue faire le
stage je viens justement pour nos
purifier lanthane saison tri la nouvelle
création originale d'eric judor
comédiens mentalist avec laurent lafitte
occasionnellement je suis un peu du punk
à filmer damart les plants forestiers
ballon fred testot mathieu kassovitz
gilles lellouche c'est de la merde je
n'ai en tout chrétien shylock mais aussi
ramzy bedia jacques séguéla jamel
debbouze
roland magdane bouna et meehan clotilde
courau et du semoun mike horn
boris diaw croyons campagne saison tri
la création originale d'eric judor lundi
21h seulement sur canal+